credit reports the basis for the single
most important three-digit number in
your whole life other than of course 311
the Beatles of rock rock lettering
credit enables businesses to know who to
lend to it's critical to our economy and
it always has been
millions of people use credit to buy the
things that add up to a better living
well there's sure a lot of things that
I'd like to buy for better living how
about giving me a little credit
nobody gives you credit John that's
something you have to earn to earn
credit first you have to develop your
character you have to have capacity to
pay your bills and third you need some
capital scoring high on these three C's
is essential to earn a good credit
rating of course back then there was a
fourth C determining your access to
credits namely what color you were
little bit weird that one didn't make
the movie but but you might be surprised
at just how many aspects of your life
your credit report can affect because
it's not just banks deciding whether to
lend you money it's also landlords
deciding whether to rent you an
apartment
insurers setting your rates and even
employers using it to decide whether or
not to hire you
47% of employers do conduct credit
checks on new potential hires and it is
legal if the employer gets permission
from the applicant
that's right nearly half of employers
delve into credit histories when hiring
I just look on Craigslist because you'll
find credit checks are required in all
sorts of job listings from managing a
Benihana in Cincinnati to this one which
reads who runs those fireworks tents it
could be you application with good
credit check required which is clearly
ridiculous they don't need to bring
credit into that job they just need to
ask the question what do you think of
fireworks and then hear the answer
fireworks off consider oh oh you love
lighting those cuz
the only three digits they need to see
are the ones on that person's two hands
there there are there are three big
credit reporting firms Equifax Experian
and TransUnion all three aggressively
market their products for uses beyond
lending for instance listen to how
Experian convinces employers that your
credit may reflect your future job
performance if you manage your credit
well then it's very likely you're going
to manage the company's money well yeah
is it though because look at me my
credit is probably fine but I routinely
waste HBO's money on stupid costumes
pyrotechnic displays and checkered dress
shirts
I clearly cannot manage this company's
money well as well as the TransUnion
their website explicitly states that
credit reports help employers make
decisions quickly and easily when
deciding on potential candidates which
is a little surprising given this
exchange between a representative from
TransUnion and an Oregon Legislature
what is the evidence that there's a
strong correlation between accessing an
applicant's credit history and eventual
problems of loss to the employer or to
the clients I guess in that case I would
say that there at this point we don't
have any research to show any
statistical correlation between what's
in somebody's credit report and their
job performance or their likelihood to
commit fraud okay so they admit there is
no evidence of a correlation which does
make sense because a good credit score
could mean you're unlikely to commit
fraud but it could also mean that you're
soaking amazing at it you've never been
caught
and I'm incidentally not thirty seconds
later that guy said this given all
things equal between two or three job
applicants for person as a high high
amount of debt versus somebody who
doesn't and all things other being equal
well maybe they want to consider that so
wait
he's saying there's no proof of a
correlation but you're free to imagine
that there is which is not a strong
argument I can imagine that eating
alphabet soup will increase
my vocabulary that does not make it
indubitable indubitable ein you ate a
lot of letters yesterday but look giving
too much credence to credit reports as a
measure of character may be a big
mistake
first over half the debt on credit
reports comes from medical expenses and
it seems unfair to judge someone for
that no one chooses to be sick with the
possible exception of Julianne Moore
taking a run at Best Actress but but
also credit reports can contain a
shocking number of errors a new
government study found about 25 percent
of consumers have an error in one of
their credit reports the study also
found about 1 in 20 had significant
errors that could cause them to pay more
for a car loan or a mortgage just think
about that warning for had an error and
1 in 20 was seriously wrong and that is
not good if every 20th frosty that
Wendy's sold turned out to be a cup of
warm goat semen we would want some
accountability and we'd want it fast
at least freeze it and
and look those those errors can be
anything from including debt that you've
already repaid to mixing you up with
someone else entirely take what happened
to a woman called Judy Thomas she
couldn't figure out why she kept getting
turned down for loans until she looked
at her credit report
I saw debt from Utah Medical Center I
saw debt from a veterinarian clinic in
Utah I saw collections for a Judith
Kendall
Judith Kendall mmm not Judy Thomas crank
what's going through your mind what the
hell she doing on my credit report the
hell's her debt doing on my credit
report Wow how can someone call Judy
Thomas be mixed up with Judith Kendal
and also if she's going to be mistaken
for anyone how is it not Lesley Stahl
because that is spooky and it actually
gets worse because if a credit reporting
agency matches your name to a list of
suspected criminals
the US has sanctions against as they did
with Amit Patel you may be in for an
unpleasant surprise after being denied
his dream apartment he asked his
landlord why as an answer the landlord
forwarded his credit report can you read
this for me what does that say
terrorists holy that is terrible
because one he is not a terrorist and
two I do hope we have a better strategy
for dealing with terrorists than
flagging their credit reports and
denying them their dream apartments what
not in America not in America and and
being mixed up with a terrorist is not
even the worst thing a credit bureau can
do to someone
Helen McGill was shocked when she went
to buy a travel trailer to learn she was
dead the financial manager came out and
said do you have like a copy of your
card because you keep coming up deceased
so I was like there's no way three major
credit bureaus listed her is deceased I
even paid at that point to to get my
credit score you can't get anything when
you're deceased
no credit score there's nothing you
don't even exist just one error on your
credit report and suddenly the world
treats you like a mean girl treats the
high school debate team you're nothing
Amberly you don't even exhaust and and
here is the thing it would be bad enough
if this just involved the three big
credit bureaus but on top of that there
are now hundreds of different companies
providing even broader background checks
which may bundle credit information with
things like criminal or driving records
and while some companies appear to
operate responsibly others like general
information services or G's - things
that make you doubt their judgment we
actually found this fun video they made
featuring snow white coming to them for
help
now Barry tail isn't an industry that we
specialize in but lucky for you our
magic mirror can find anything worth
locating if only you were in the
insurance industry we created tons of
solutions for those guys
oh my who's that it fairy we're an equal
opportunity employer whoa hold up
there's not a homophobic fairy joke
because it's hard enough to accept
judgment from a company that would do
that let alone deliver it with the
acting skill of a shy third grader and
background check agencies can take all
the problems of credit reporting while
adding a few more and let's begin with
the obvious here as we've discussed
before on this show a criminal record
does not necessarily mean you're a bad
person or that you shouldn't be hired
but if you are going to use a criminal
background check to make decisions at
the very least they should be accurate
and frequently they are not take Samuel
Jackson from Chicago no relation to the
actor obviously or to the three
different sex offenders one company
confused him with even though one of
those convictions happened when Jackson
was just three years old or as his
lawyer puts it the background check
company was aware that mr. Jackson is
only 30 years old so it clearly couldn't
have been him and obviously he can be
all three sex offenders at the same time
of course of course not because there's
only one person who could pull off being
three sex offenders at the same time and
that is mr. Neil Patrick Harris I'm not
saying is I'm saying he has got the
performance chops to make you believe it
is possible if you put it might if you
put his mind to it he could be the
literal triple threat he's that good
he's that good a performer and and
remember these mistakes can cost people
housing and jobs it is no wonder that
many firms have wound up facing legal
challenges for instance just last year
GIS and their affiliates had to geez out
13 million dollars in fines and damages
and while they admit no wrongdoing
they've now lost so much money their
next shitty video is probably just gonna
be a filthy parrot in an old warehouse
screaming Polly wants a background check
and at this point you are probably
thinking well holy
I should probably check my background
and credit reports well the good news is
under a law called the Fair Credit
Reporting Act the big three credit firms
are required to give you a copy once a
year and there's even an official site
where you can get yours but if you do
spot an error your trouble may just be
beginning remember Judy Thomas it took
her a surprisingly long time to get her
credit fixed it became a six year battle
with credit agencies requiring box loads
of Correspondence to try and prove that
she was Judy Thomas not Judith Kendall
all to no avail I also hired a local
attorney to try and straighten it out we
had everything certified um that this is
Judy Thomas this is where I live I've
never gone by the name of Kendall I've
never even been to Utah let alone owing
a cable company in Utah and what
happened nothing oh come on at this
point I'm surprised you didn't just go
you know what kit I'm Judith Kendal I'm
moving to Utah and I'm getting a sick
pet and a cable package at least then my
life will make Sun King sense to me it
is it's probably not surprising that
when we crunch the numbers we discover
that the three big credit bureaus have
been the subject of the most complaints
to the CFPB since the start of last year
and they may say that sometimes they
receive inaccurate data from creditors
of the mistakes don't originate with
them but if that's true their method for
resolving those problems clearly needs
to be better and in a settlement
agreement just last March they actually
pledged to improve their dispute
resolution process but before you get
too hopeful about that it's worth noting
the industry has claimed for decades
that they are always improving their
accuracy and yet for 25 years now the
news stories about them have had
something of a similar tone we saw a
recent study that said 25 percent of
credit reports had err serious enough to
deny you credit a new study finds a
staggering number of credit reports
contain mistakes
a new study says credit reports
frequently have errors that can be very
costly for consumers a survey by the US
Public Interest Research Group found
nearly one-third of all credit reports
contain serious errors you don't have to
spend long preparing a broadcast about
credit agencies before you learn one
simple truth everyone and I mean
everyone has a horror story it's it's
pretty obvious that problems with credit
agencies are a classic new story
trunk-like oldest person dies or scary
new teen sex trends coming up we've all
heard of Netflix and chill but what does
it mean when your team says they're
going to Hulu and it is not as
innocent as it sounds there is the point
is there is nothing new about this
problem in fact when we were researching
Judy Thomas's story we found a news clip
about a lawsuit from 2002 that gave us
deja vu it was the culmination of a
six-year battle for a Judy Thomas who
tried repeatedly to get TransUnion to
clear up the mistakes on her credit
report another Judy Thomas some Judy
Thomas was not even the only Judy Thomas
this had happened to the lesson here is
pretty simple if you or someone you know
is named Judy Thomas give up there is no
hope in life for Judy's like you and if
anything things are even worse with
background check companies because they
are also required to give you a copy of
your report if you request it but
there's a massive loophole there because
unlike the credit bureaus most of them
don't keep files on all consumers they
just search for data when someone pays
them - and if you're about to apply for
a job or an apartment you might think
well I want to be sure that there isn't
a problem on my report so I'll just buy
it first myself so we actually asked
these companies if they'd let us do that
and they all said no meaning if they
confuse you with a sex offender you
might not find out until that job or
apartment is all but gone and of course
you know who you have lost it to don't
you Neil Patrick Harris you wouldn't
even think he could take a certified
public accountant job but he can and he
does it so well and he's
a likeable while he does it he is so
good
no now to be fair to be fair here some
companies will sell you your own report
so we had some of our staffers buy their
own background checks from a few
companies while most of them came back
fine five of our staffers reports
including alias names that they'd never
heard of before
and one staffer Charles Wilson was
mistaken for a man who was indicted for
Medicaid fraud in Florida now now that
site did say Charles his listing was
pending verification and it was later
removed from his report but it was still
too late
because by that time in a Spartacus
style show of support our entire office
had already rallied around Charles and
committed Medicaid fraud because we care
about him and listen given the stakes
here you would hope that these
background check companies are being
closely monitored
but as this FTC official admits there
was no lahrman amount that they don't
know is there any kind of national list
of these companies no there isn't
so we don't know how many companies
companies are even out there no we don't
and I think that's one of the challenges
yeah no that's one of the
challenges you can't just lose track of
how many background check companies
there are the way that we've all lost
track of the number of Oreo flavors
roots be afloat are you kin kidding me
you are sick Oreo you're all sick and
and the problem is this whole industry
seems uncomfortably complacent in fact
remember that FTC study that I mentioned
at the start which showed that one in
twenty credit reports had serious errors
an industry trade group put out a press
release in response to that with the
title FTC report confirms credit reports
are accurate arguing that it showed
ninety-five percent of consumers are
unaffected by errors in their credit
report but when you are holding records
for more than 200 million individuals
that 5 percent error rate affects 10
million people they're basically saying
great news everyone
we only up a group equivalent to the
entire population of Sweden
King greatest if only we could make this
whole industry understand the Jeopardy
that they're placing people in you know
what maybe we can because remember the
big three credit companies Equifax
Experian and TransUnion well we started
three terrible companies with names that
are problematically similar to this
specifically Equifax Experian and
TransUnion what do those companies do
great question if you just visit Equifax
comm you'll see that they take shelter
animals to customers homes where the
animals lick peanut butter off people's
genitals before being immediately
returned to the shelter Equifax is just
an awful company but but don't worry
Equifax I can't imagine anyone will
mistake them for you and and if you go
to Experian comm you'll find a company
that sends people to whisper passages
from mine camp into babies ears with the
permission of these are the baby nor the
parents and finally don't miss trams
annyeong comm where you can buy these
delicious-looking stakes made from the
flesh of dead orcas who worked at
SeaWorld it would it would clearly be an
absolute disaster for the credit
agencies if they were mistaken for any
of these companies but don't worry I'm
sure that won't happen 95% of the time
and apparently that's good enough right
you